l'espace réglée du bas de la rivière
propose désormais diverses activités
yoga gospel tai chi ou encore danse
orientale et bien d'autres aurélie carpi
professeur de danse indienne propose des
cours une fois par semaine à l'espace
régler un cadre qu'elle juge agréable et
propice à la détente
et bien depuis le début de l'année
scolaire 2014 nous avons mis en place
des cours de danse indienne et orientale
dédiés tant aux enfants qu'aux adultes à
l'espace régler le mercredi après midi
entre 17h et 20h donc ce sont des cours
qui sont proposés dans un cadre plutôt
d'activités extrascolaires et bien moi
c'est un espace qui m'a beaucoup plu
parce que j'ai été convié lors des
vacances scolaires pour pour animer
l'espace régner dans le cadre des
journées marmaille où on a pu organiser
un spectacle de danse
indochinois où il y avait donc d'autres
associations et puis j'ai trouvé cet
endroit vraiment plaisant agréable et
c'était l'occasion de développer un
petit peu le bas de la rivière et faire
connaître un peu plus encore ce ballet
ce pas ce beau jardin qui peut
accueillir petits et grands
tout au long de la journée c'est un
cadre très agréable pour pouvoir
s'évader de tout ce stress qu'on a au
quotidien au travail ou à la maison eh
bien les cours ont débuté par des élèves
tout à fait novice qui ne connaissait
pas la danse indienne ou parfois même
qu'ils n'avaient jamais pratiqué de
danse encore ce sont des élèves qui
m'ont rencontré sur des événements
notamment jardin de l'état qui nous ont
rejoint donc au début de l'année
scolaire elles ont commencé par la danse
indienne et puis il y en a d'autres qui
nous ont rejoint tout récemment il ya
trois semaines donc deborah qu' une
toute nouvelle élève qui pratique à la
fois les cours de danse indienne et
cours de danse orientale donc elle suit
les deux courts d'affilée il y en a
trois ou quatre mêmes qui sont dans ce
cas là qui pratiquent les deux courts
qui enchaîne sur la danse orientale
après la danse indienne pour chacune des
élèves ses cours de danse représente un
véritable moment de détente pour elle
laisse passerelle et d'un cadre de
verdure reposant et relaxant un lieu
idéal pour découvrir la culture indienne
et orientale à travers la danse
j'ai commencé avec des cours
particuliers et donc depuis peu je suis
des cours à régler avec elle c'est super
avec le parc boisé et c'est vraiment un
truc c'est pas comme dans une salle de
danse une salle de fêtes par exemple
voyez c'est vraiment là c'est c'est plus
convivial c'est surtout pour la danse
indienne par rapport au parc en fait
c'est vraiment l'idéal je dirais ma
fille est une passionnée de danse elle
fit de la danse depuis
pam bientôt cinq ans vient chaque cours
voir comment ça se passe et voir
l'avancement des cours et
dans la préparation spectacles ont déjà
on a un très beau cadre à l'espace
régler ici
avec de superbes salles et il ya une
belle organisation et voilà fait que
quelques mois que je pratique la danse
orientale avec aurélie
c'est une danse très très agréable ça
peut être une danse pour les femmes mais
aussi bien les hommes aussi peuvent
pratiquer et
ça ça nous permet de nous de nous
détendre déjà après le boulot ça se
passe en général le mercredi soir pour
le moment dans le bas de la rivière
donc ça permet de détendre après le
boulot de nous des stressés et puis de
nous exprimer déjà à l'espace raid
laisser un cadre comme vous pouvez le
constater magnifique
de magnifiques de la verdure partout on
a une salle superbe une très très grande
salle qui nous permet de de contenir
beaucoup beaucoup de danseuses de
personnes
franchement c'est un cadre magnifique